no matter what kind of fps player you
are the best ps4 and ps5 shooters have
something to keep you entertained by
yourself or with friends all of our
picks are arranged in alphabetical order
and playable on both ps4 and ps5 and
some have ps5 enhancements
here are our picks for the 20 best
playstation shooters
apex legends with 2019's apex legends
respawn entertainment brought the flair
for movement that defined his titanfall
series to the battle royale genre apex
legends has hero abilities like
overwatch a revolutionary ping system
you can talk without a mic and a roster
of firearms that just feel really good
to use
all this and you got a battle royale
that hangs with the best of them
battlefield one taking place during
world war one battlefield 1 offers a
vignette style campaign with multiple
perspectives on the great war drive a
tank fight on foot pilot a biplane
battlefield 1's multi-perspectives
provides a campaign of unmatched variety
dice's military shooter is one of the
best in the series and well worth
playing for a single player alone
bioshock the collection bioshock the
collection offers an inexpensive ticket
to some of gaming's most unforgettable
locales the collection has it all
bioshock bioshock 2 bioshock infinite
and all of the trilogies dlc
the original bioshock is still the best
of the bunch even 14 years after
bioshock's initial release nothing is
quite like rapture the 1940s era city at
the bottom of the sea solid shooting
mechanics keep the game exciting and big
garish personalities keep the story
enjoyable through its famous twist
bioshock 2 was released two and a half
years later and it feels like a retread
in many ways the player returns to
rapture but this time as a big daddy
what it lacks in novelty bioshock 2
makes up for in depth and a wealth of
new combat options
2013's bioshock infinite is the most
polarizing of the bunch taking the
player to colombia a floating city in
the sky it's a beautiful setting where
early 20th century architectural
grandeur belies a dark and bigoted core
much has been said about the ways
infinite handles its core themes but
riding around on skyrails and slamming
down on unsuspecting enemies below is
undeniably still a ton of fun
borderlands 3.
borderlands 3 doesn't do too much that's
new but it does plenty that's better
some are small like the tweak to the
minimap that makes detecting changes in
elevation way easier some are big like
the fact that you have a spaceship which
you can use to fly among locations
environments are varied from the pandora
desert to a mountainous world inspired
by the himalayas to a futuristic city in
the midst of a hostile corporate
takeover
call of duty modern warfare remastered
modern warfare is the game that brought
call of duty into the present abandoning
the beaches of normandy in favor of
modern conflict in a fictionalized
united states own 21st century wars
missions like all gillied up are still a
blast to play today and it's hard to
beat some of the classic multiplayer
maps like shipment and the game has
never looked better thanks to the
remastering for modern consoles
call of duty war zone call of duty
warzone makes some smart tweaks to the
battle royale formula for instance the
game introduced the gulag a prison where
downed players are transported for 1v1
gunfights with the winner earning a
respawn this free to play fps features
the tight gun play steady progression
and vehicular mayhem that have made call
of duty multiplayer a popular mainstay
for almost 15 years
destiny 2 destiny 2 is a pioneering live
service game and an endlessly fun mashup
of fps gameplay and an mmo style meta
whether you're playing by yourself
tackling a strike with friends or going
on the series famous and famously long
raids destiny 2 has something for
everyone adam bungie's flair for lore
and some of the best proper nouns in the
business and you've got an evocative
world that simply could not feel better
to shoot through with a group of friends
doom 2016 doom 2016 was a big surprise
reinvigorating the pioneering shooter
series after a 12 year gap it emphasized
frantic gameplay strafe heavy gunfights
and a story that took itself just
seriously enough to work the multiplayer
remains underwhelming but the single
player campaign is a hard charging fps
that keeps the action moving at all
times this was the best kind of reboot
it considered the things that made the
original games special and
recontextualized them in a thoroughly
modern game
do maternal do maternal was less focused
than doom 2016 but it's a magnificent
ballot of bloodshed nonetheless do
maternal serves up more of what made the
2016 reboot sing
new abilities like flame belch and ice
bomb injected fresh dynamism into an
already brilliant combat system detailed
degradation on enemies offer at-a-glance
updates on your combat progress which
fits in brilliantly with the game's
hellfire brimstone and blood aesthetic
outside of firefights eternal is
slightly more of a mixed bag the lore is
too self-serious and the platforming can
be confusing still when you're in a
fight do maternal plays unlike anything
else on the market
fallout 4.
bethesda made big strides in terms of
controls with fallout 4 delivering
better shooting mechanics than in
previous entries while retaining his
timeless role-playing game structure
it's a lengthy and expansive rpg that
serves up plenty of interesting quests
in the wasteland surrounding boston
multiple factions to side with her
against a massive world to explore and a
story that reacts to your choices there
are some downgrades role playing isn't
as nuanced as in previous games and
companions don't have much to say but
they're made in favor of deeper
simulational elements plus for creatives
fallout 4 has extensive base building
mechanics which you can use to build
impressive hideouts
far cry 5 if you've played far cry 3 or
4 you'll know what to expect from far
cry 5. it's a thoroughly entertaining
romp in the montana wilderness
nonetheless players take on the role of
a junior deputy sheriff attempting to
take down cult leader joseph seed and
his followers the project at eden's gate
as in previous far cry games expect to
take out outposts either with stealth or
sheer force and listen to a charismatic
villain deliver his monologue far cry 5
is a great time in single-player and
co-op
metro exodus
the third and final game in developer
4a's metro trilogy exodus issues tight
linear levels for a pseudo-open world as
protagonist artiem and his fellow
survivors exit the underground in favor
of a speeding train across the frozen
soviet landscape based on dmitry
glukovsky's novel metro 2035 metro
exodus is a rare modern shooter with
great battles and storytelling in a
gorgeous world
[Music]
overwatch blizzard's hero shooter was
the defining fps for much of the
previous generation featuring a diverse
and massive roster of aesthetically and
mechanically distinct characters flashy
abilities memorable maps and frequent
seasonal events and even if you're not
good at shooting that's okay healers are
a vital part of any team's composition
but be sure to invite a few friends to
play with you because overwatch is a
multiplayer only game
pray
pray isn't as propulsive violent or
kinetic as other entries on this list in
fact you can sneak through much of this
sci-fi immersive sim without firing a
bullet instead the draw is the setting
arcane's games like its dishonored
series are known for their play your way
approach to level design powers such as
the ability to transform and play as
objects in the environment instantly get
the mind racing with possibility
and the 2018 expansion moon crash
transplants the core gameplay into a
rogue-like structure
[Music]
rage 2
co-developed by id software and
avalanche studios group rage 2 has the
tight gun play you expect from the
creators of doom and wolfenstein in a
post-apocalyptic desert world the open
world isn't as exciting as you might
expect from avalanche but the fights are
hectic gory fun and the tone is less
serious than the previous underwhelming
rage
rainbow six siege a brilliant tactical
shooter rainbow six siege is one of the
best fps games available today the
shooting feels great and responsive but
planning and teamwork are just as
important rainbow six siege has only
gotten better since launching way back
in 2015
new maps and operators create an
engrossing tactical experience even
after playing hundreds of hours if
you're a fan of tactical shooters that
require excellent teamwork rainbow six
siege is hard to beat
[Music]
super hot
super hot has a simple premise time only
moves when you move and it
wholeheartedly commits to that concept
more of a puzzle game than a traditional
fps super hot asks players to think
carefully about every move they make and
every bullet they fire it's innovative
meta and has spawned two pseudo sequels
super hot vr and super hot mind control
delete
titanfall 2
the best first person shooter campaign
since half-life 2 it depends on who you
ask but respawn entertainment's briskly
paced sci-fi fps undeniably has some of
the best moment-to-moment gameplay of
any title on this list sprint slide
double jump shoot sprint and shoot some
more as you blast through some of the
best levels of the last generation add
in a suite of multiplayer modes and you
have a full package that few fps can
rival
wolfenstein the new order wolfenstein
the new order is a stellar reinvention
of the classic fps franchise with great
shooting and strong stealth plus it
features a compelling alternate history
with its fair share of indiscriminate
nazi slaughter and yes a touching
romance between hiro bj blaskovich and
his lover anya the 2014 game looks
slightly dated at this point but the
action and storytelling are still a
major success
[Music]
wolfenstein 2 the new colossus
machine game's second wolfenstein game
is a nazi killing extravaganza that pays
equal attention to rip roaring action
and ensemble storytelling
the story moments land the dialogue is
strong and the gun play is as good as
ever we especially love how the new
colossus handles progression overall the
new colossus is a fps with enough hyper
violence and an over-the-top story that
would even make quentin tarantino blush
and then applaud
and that does it for our 20 favorite ps5
and ps4 first person shooters what were
your favorites and was there anything
you think we missed if you enjoyed this
video make sure to give that like button
a little pistol whip and subscribe for
more content around the games you love
and i'll see you guys next time
you